Ähm, ähm, Stefan Titzler? Ja. Nichts, nichts, nichts, nichts, nichts, nichts, nichts. Schön. Wir sind auch. Gut, haben wir das auch. Herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr da seid, zwei neue Ausgaben von Debut, das Podcast-Ufo, mit natürlich niemand geringerem als Stefan Tippitoppitititzler. Und Florian den Will, hat das Intro mich gerade beleidigt? Ja. Ich habe es nicht genau verstanden. Ich glaube, das ist auch besser so, das Intro hat dich intensivst beleidigt. Ich habe immer Angst, dass mich das Intro beleidigt. Ja, glaube ich auch, immer je schlechter es verständlich ist, desto mehr kannst du davon ausgehen, dass es dich beleidigt. Das ist mir gehe ich aber davon aus. Nicht das Intro, dass dich beleidigt, sondern Mike. Von Mike kommt dieses Intro, das zweite Intro schon. Und direkt die Beleidigung in dein Gesicht. Wie willst du antworten? Ist jetzt ein Beef, hast du jetzt ein Battle Rap vor, ein Sinti, ein Sinti Solo oder so? Weil ich bin so harmoniebedürftig, dass ich eher so einen Michael Jackson-artigen Heal-the-World-Song als Battle Rap antworten würde, als jetzt nochmal so ein aggressives Ich-bin-der--der-Beste-der-die-dicksten-Eier Battle-Rap-Antwort. Ich würde eher so ein Aua-Aua-Aua-Song. Ja, in der Art Band-Aid geben. Ein grosses Pflaster-Song, um das Kriegsbeil zu begraben. Ja, finde ich gut. Du bist ja im Hip-Hop ein Revolutionär, mit deiner versöhnlichen Art geworden, muss man ja auch tatsächlich sagen. Du hast wahnsinnig viel Spendengelder gesammelt für Graffiti-Entfernung, das kam nicht gut an. Da hast du dir leider das falsche Angebot gesucht. Habe ich heute gesehen auf dem Weg hierher, ist immer mein schönster Anblick, wie Leute Graffiti wegmachen. Das ist für mich immer so der, es gibt ja Kriege, Weltkriege, aber es gibt auch ganz kleine Mikrokriege, die teilweise über Jahrzehnte gehen. Und ich finde, einer der interessantesten Mikrokriege ist der zwischen Graffiti-Artists und dem Ordnungsamt. Genau. Und ehrlich gesagt, das Ordnungsamt schafft es ja mittlerweile mit verschiedenen Techniken zu reinigen, das besser wegzubekommen und so. Aber man sieht an den Leuten, die das wegmachen, immer schon dieses, ja, das kommt ja jetzt hier wieder hin. Ja. Ich werde das ja nicht für ewig diese Stadt gerade schön machen, das ist ein temporäres Okay. Vor allem diese tapferen Ordnungsamt-Frontsoldaten kämpfen seit Jahrzehnten einen Krieg, der verloren ist. Die wissen, der Aufwand, es zu entfernen, ist zwanzig mal so gross, wie der Aufwand, es hinzusprayen. Also das ist ja verloren, aber die machen trotzdem weiter. Wo sind denn eigentlich diese Wandbeläge, wo das einfach wieder abperlt? Haben wir von der Lotuspflanze nichts gelernt? Ich glaube nichts. Dem nichts gelernt. Völlig ignorant. Wir haben nicht zugehört. Wir saßen in der letzten Reihe und haben Speskes gemacht. Und Käsekästchen gespielt, während die Lotuspflanze uns die Lösungen zu allen Problemen gegeben hat. Gesagt hat primär zu dem einen Problem, wie Wasser abgewiesen wird, beziehungsweise vielleicht sogar so Spray-Dinger. Aber das ist halt ein Wettrüsten so, weil dann muss halt die Hip-Hop-Graffiti-Industrie aufrüsten und bessere Spraydosen machen, die Anti-Lotus-Effekt-Spraydosen. Und wo endet das denn? Wo endet das denn letzten Endes, dieses unendliche Aufrüsten? Aber ich glaube immer, was ich nicht verstehe, ist, warum haben die Graffiti-Artists mehr Grinsen im Gesicht, wenn sie etwas drauf taggen, obwohl es weggemacht wird, als der Saubermann, der es wegmacht, weil der gute eine will da sein, der andere will nicht da sein. Ja, der eine wird bezahlt, der andere nicht. Ja, also. Ihr müsst nicht beide mit einem ähnlich grossen Grinsen da stehen und das machen, bis wir das wegmachen. Es ist kein Grinsen, wenn ich diese Ordnungsamtmitarbeiter sehe, es ist ein ernstes, in sich gekehrtes, pflichtbewusstes Dienst tun, was ich in den Augen ansehe. Was eine eigene Art von Glücklichkeit sein kann, von Lebensglück, einfach pflichtbewusst sein Dienst zu tun. Ganz anders natürlich, deswegen ist diese Streitkräfte so interessant, weil du hast einmal so diese rebellischen Ausdrucks Graffiti-Rebellen und andererseits diese Pflichtbeamten, die das kalt, die da wirklich die schönsten Graffitis vom Tag bis zum grössten dreidimensional fluoreszierenden Neon-Ding einfach wegkärchern. Bis zur Mittagspause wegkärchern. Deine schöne Bifi-Roll und dann geht's weiter.
Ein harter Cut und die ganze Zeit
dieser eine Gedanke, wer zum Teufel
ist Crazy Nick 3.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, das ist genau die Frage.
Eigentlich müssten die ja richtige
Graffiti-Experten sein, richtige Street-Art-Experten,
die genau wissen, ah, das war
wieder Ronny F.,
und das war wieder Cynthia Rubensberg. Die Horde. Und die müssen sich ja richtig gut auskennen eigentlich. Ja, ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist wirklich ein verlorener Kampf. Bei uns im Haus ist es auch manchmal, da wird dann draufgesprayt, dann wird es wieder weggemacht, und es ist ein Komm und Gehen, und man weiß nicht. Aber es ist auch egal, lass das doch einfach da dran. Aber meinst du, ich würde mich gerne mal mit einem von denen unterhalten und fragen, meinen Sie, Sie haben schon mal einen Banksy entfernt? Dann sagt er so, was kann ich sagen? Ja? Warum nicht? Da unten an der Reinhardbrücke oder was? Ja, bei mir kommt weg, ich habe jetzt, seitdem ich diesen neuen Wegmache 3000 Blitz Apparello hier habe, da ist kein Kunstwerk von mir immer sicher. Sagen Sie mal, was ist denn der Banksy anders als hier Crazy Nick 3? Das ist Kunst, das wird für Millionen Dollar im Madison Square Garden. Der Nick, der macht auch schöne Tags. Und? Nick? Ja. Danke. Crazy Nick. Was? Ich meine, wenn ich ihn sehe, sage ich ihm, dass sie es gut finden. Springen Sie mal auf und ab. Macht Ihr Rucksack nicht die Geräusche von der Spray-Dose? Springen Sie mal auf und ab. Nee,, ich bin jetzt gerade hier hingesetzt. Hat man diese Kugeln drin, damit man die erkennt, wie diese Klapper, die man so an Kinderschänder im Mittelalter rangemacht hat? Gute Idee, eigentlich stimmt. Das ist ein bisschen, dass Sie das Klappern von diesen Spraydosen eher so ein bisschen lauter machen. Ja, das ist eine Verschwörung des Ordnungsamtes, zu sagen, tut in deren Hauptwerkzeug ratternde, klingelnde, kleine Kinderzähne rein, haben wir eh genug. Vielleicht arbeiten die mit der Zahnfee zusammen, dass die da die Kinderzähne kriegen, tun die in die Dosen rein, damit die die erkennen können, wenn die nachts über den Bahnhof wetzen. Ja, das ist, wenn die auf und abspringen, parkourartig, dass die dann klingen. Hat jemand schon mal probiert, das rauszunehmen, diese Kugel, was auch immer das ist? ob es trotzdem funktioniert oder ob es dann einfach gar nicht mehr geht? Vielleicht brauchst du es gar nicht. Ich glaube, es geht dann gar nicht mehr, dann wird das dickflüssig, aber vielleicht ist das auch wirklich einfach ein Mythos, der die Ordnungsämter den reingepflanzt haben. Aber macht es natürlich noch interessanter, glaube ich, diese Gefahr, dass deine Waffe dich verraten kann mit dem Klappern und Klingeln, das macht es natürlich auch noch mal spannender. Hast du aus den Kugelschreibern auch immer die Kugeln rausgemacht? Die Kugeln nicht, nur die Federn. Die Federn rausgemacht. Es gibt ja Leute, die haben die gesammelt in Kugelschreibern, die man kennt, diese Kugelschreiber. Da musst du aber Hand anlegen, oder? Nee, Tinten kannst du nicht einfach so. Ne, Tinten. Tinten?
Wann ich in diesen Tinten, wo drin waren, waren diese Kugeln?
Weil nicht die Kugel, die Kugeln hat man ja nicht rausgeklaut. Nee, du hast recht, in den Tintenpatronen.
In den Tintenpatronen waren ja auch diese kleinen Kugeln.
Genau, die war oben die Kugel, die den Eingang versperrt hat, konntest du so durchdrücken.
Genau.
Und wenn die leer war, dann war die Kugel noch drin. Die habe ich auch gesammelt, ja.
Die hast du gesammelt?
Ja.
Und dann?
Habe ich gemerkt, dass jedes zweite Schulkind die sammelt. Jetzt man lieber Wissen sammeln soll in der Schule, oder? Ja. Wäre besser gewesen. Wäre das nicht besser gewesen? Ja, wäre besser gewesen. Wo sind die Kugeln jetzt? Ja, die sind mir runtergefallen da auf dem Weg nach Hause. Noch immer fahren Autos gegen Wände und Kinder fallen hin, weil du diese in Ebersbach diese Kugeln hast. Graffiti-Sprayer stürzen auf der Flucht vor dem Ordnungsamt. Verdammt nochmal, die Kugeln! Kugeln sind mein Niedergang in jeder Form! Mein Größerfreund ist die Kugel. In jeder Form. Hauptsache Kugelform. In jeder Form. Ja, stimmt schon. Ich glaube, das ist genauso so irgendwas, was alle sammeln und dadurch völlig wertlos wird, wie damals diese Päckchen mit den Euromünzen. Als der Euro rauskam, diese Päckchen von der Zentralbank, was auch immer, mit jeder Münze einmal. Starterpack. Jede Münze einmal, damit man nicht aufwendig Sachen kaufen muss, um die Münzen zu haben. Und am Ende hast du, weil du jede Münze einmal hast, hast du? Hast du? Dann 3,80 Euro. Und die habe ich tatsächlich auch noch zu Hause im Päckchen. Aber wahrscheinlich wurden 99 Prozent von diesem Päckchen nicht aufgemacht, weil man sagte, irgendwann in zehn Jahren ist die nicht viel wert. 3,80 Euro ist nicht so weit weg. Das war trotzdem falsch. Okay, hätte ich wohl in der Schule besser aufpassen müssen. Was ich tatsächlich lange gesammelt habe, sind die Plastikdeckel von Joghurts. So. Aber nicht die Alufoliendeckel, sondern bei diesen großen Bechern, bei diesen Halbliterbechern, 0,5 Kilobechern, da war oben nochmal ein Deckel drauf. Und die habe ich gesammelt, bei mir in der Küche aufgestapelt zu einem grossen Turm, weil ich das interessant fand, weil die sind ja alle so fast durchsichtig. Aber wenn du da fünf hintereinander tust, dann wird es immer milchiger. Und ich dachte mir, immer milchiger. Wie viele Deckel brauche ich, damit ich gar nicht mehr durchschauen kann? Und wie viele waren es? Neun. Sehr wenig. Warum, woher kommt dieses Sammeln, dieses viel von einer Sache wollen? Ich glaube, zum einen ist es so ein Ding, sich quasi auch dem Auge etwas auszusetzen, was es so nicht gibt mehr, was kein anderer jemals gewitness hat. Du hast zum Beispiel halt einfach gemerkt, wann kann man nicht mehr durchgucken, ist es gar nicht wirklich transparent, du hast ein bisschen hinter die Fassade geschaut, dieser Deckelinustrie. Richtig. Auf der anderen Seite ist es einfach Macht über so ganz viele kleine Dinge. Deswegen ist man auch Reis gerne, glaube ich. Ja, absolut. Weil du viel von einer kleinen Sau, oder Linsen oder so. Herrlich. Und deswegen sind All-You-Can-Eat-Buffets ja immer sehr beliebt. Nicht, weil du mehr isst, sondern weil du einfach diese, du kannst aus dem Vollen schöpfen. Richtig. Ich glaube, das sind zwei Arten von Sammeln. Einmal das Komplettierende Sammeln. So, ich will alle Star-Wars-Action-Figuren haben, alle. Und meine Reise ist erst beendet, wenn ich alle habe. Oder ich sammle ganz viele Jar Jar Binks. Ich will alle Jar Jar Binks oder ich will alle Klick-DVDs haben, dieser Adam-Sandler-Film Klick. Ich will alle DVDs von diesem einen Film haben. Ich glaube, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Arten von Sammlern. Da müsste man ein Streitgespräch geben, von einem dem Komplettierenden Sammlern. Da müsste man ein sehr, sehr langweiliges Streitgespräch geben. Ja, also falls ihr einer von den beiden Sammlern seid, schreibt uns, wir führen euch zusammen mit eurem Gegenpart. Ja. Und dann sollen wir richtig die Fetzen fliegen. Das will ich mal im Fernsehen sehen. Nicht immer Politiker von der F-Partei gegen Politiker von der S-Partei. Ich habe die F-Meinung, ja was, wirklich? Und ich habe die S-Meinung, nein, jetzt kommt der Tatort. Also so läuft es doch mittlerweile im deutschen Politikfernsehen oder nicht. Du willst aber jetzt die Fetzen fliegen. Du willst, dass da mal wieder richtig auf den Tisch gehauen wird, nicht immer nur umarmen des Dingsbums, wo ersehbares Gelaber. Richtig, richtig, richtig. Ich will, dass da wirklich Fragen geklärt werden im Fernsehen. Ich will, dass da wirklich Fragen geklärt werden im Fernsehen. Ich will, dass da wirklich Fragen geklärt werden im Fernsehen. Ja, das ist wirklich. Ja, okay, ich bin dafür bereit. Lasst mal wieder die Fetzen fliegen, so heißt dein Format, wenn Schlohundin will. Und dann lässt er da mal so zwei Parteien gegeneinander antreten, die vorher nicht wissen. So ein bisschen wie der Talk-O-Mar, den es auch hier auf Spotify gibt, oder dort auf Spotify, nachdem wo ihr uns hört, aber halt immer mit Leuten, die sich hassen. Ja. Das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Ja, du weißt halt zum Beispiel so ein Feuerschlucker gegen einen Wasserspucker oder irgendwie so. Gegen einen Trinker, einen Gruppenden Akkoholiker. Nee, ein Feuerspucker gegen einen Läufer. Ja, guck mal, das wäre doch mal eine Talkshow. Das ist doch mal eine Talkshow. Die haben sich doch viel zu sagen. Ja. Feuer, Teufel und Feuerwehrmann. Ja, oder ein Pilot und ein U-Boot-Fahrer. So, der eine ist ganz tief, der andere ist ganz hoch. Warum bist du so tief? Komm hoch! Warum bist du so hoch? Komm runter! Komm noch mal runter! Komm noch mal runter, unters Wasser! Nein, drüber! Wir fliegen oben drüber! Nein, nein, nein, nein. Und dann kommt so der Schiffwacher, wir können zusammenkommen. Wir kommen zusammen. Genau, das ist dann der Überraschungsgast, der dritte. Es sind nämlich, im Studio sehen wir immer drei Stühle, von denen aber einer immer leer ist. Und jeder denkt sich, was ist hier passiert? Hat jemand abgesagt, ist der rausgegangen? Auch in Folge 18, wenn das System schon klar ist, denkt man sich immer noch, wofür ist es hier gut? Da kommt immer derjenige oder diejenige, die die beiden verbinden kann. Genau, aber davor ist der Stuhl leer und die Kamera schneidet aber auch in den Close-up, als säße da jemand, während die anderen reden, als würde da ein Geist sitzen, der zuhört, den man nicht sieht. Und der zuständige Zimmer, was geschieht hier, was passiert da, da fehlt doch was. Bis dann irgendwann derjenige kommt, der mal gerne ein Gläschen Schnaps isst und sich gerne Feuerschlucker anschaut. Sowas. Genau, der es nicht ausschließen kann. Reinhold ist kein Alkoholiker in dem Sinne, genehmigt sich mal ab und zu ein Gläschen Eierlikörer. Du bist großer Fan vom Feuerspucken. Genau. Schlucken und spucken beide Richtungen, Feuer ist super. Und U-Boot und versus Pilot, der bis auf den Tod wird auch ausgekämpft und dann setzt sich plötzlich so ein Katamaran-Kapitän hin, die ja manchmal so ein bisschen aus dem Wasser kommen, weißt du? Ja, ja, ja. Das ist so quasi so ein bisschen übers Wasser, man könnte sagen, über diese Max-Sacker-Fliegen. Ja, stimmt. Aber auch dann wieder runter. Oder halt eine Möwe. Oder halt eine fucking Möwe. Die halt auch alle Elemente verbindet. Die kann fliegen, schwimmen, tauchen und gehen. Laufen, ja, das war's. Das Langweilige ist dir nicht eingefallen. Ich lache mich immer kaputt, wenn Vögel laufen. Wahnsinn, das ist super gut. Brauchen die mehr Energie, wenn sie laufen? Das haben wir schon mal gefragt, was ist das Gehen für die? Was verbraucht so viel Energie für uns Gehen? Eher Fliegen oder eher deren Gehen? Ich glaube, deren Gehen ist unser Sitzen und deren Fliegen ist unser Laufen. Rennen, Joggen oder spannendes Laufen? Nee, Laufen. Kommt auf die Windrichtung an. Ja, und wir sitzen ja auch lieber, als dass wir stehen.
Von daher würde ich sagen,
und deren Sitzen ist unser Liegen,
und deren Liegen, das können wir uns
nicht fucking vorstellen.
Deren Liegen ist
fucking the most amazing
shit.
Entspannendste Körperhaltung, wie es überhaupt gibt.
Deren Liegen ist unser fucking Sex. Das war die... Kurzer, kurzer Irritationsmoment aufgrund der Technik. Aber hast du die Fehlermeldung gelesen, die da stand? Ja, ich habe kaum noch Festplattenspeicher. Ich habe immer randvolle Festplatten. Immer wenn ich was runterladen will, muss ich was Altes löschen. Es ist furchtbar. Vor allem, ich denke immer so, okay, ich brauche eine grössere Festplatte. Das Problem ist ja nicht die Grösse der Festplatte, sondern dass die immer voll ist. Sondern wie man damit nagelt. So, entschuldige bitte diese mehrstündige Pause. Es gab technische Probleme, die ich beheben konnte. Du bist ein richtiger Problemlöser. Du bist ein Anpacker und Problemlöser. Ja, aber die meisten Probleme, die ich anpacke, habe ich auch selber erzeugt. Deswegen ist es so ein bisschen, eigentlich ist es Problem Gewichtheben. Ich stülpe mir die Gewichte selber auf die Stange, um dann einmal hochzuheben und dann sagen, jetzt gehe ich ins Bett. Ich hatte eher ein Problem Jonglage, aber du wolltest die Jongleur werden, die hat man nur einfach Jonglierbälle zugeworfen, so ein bisschen.
Ja, du meinst ja schon, der Jongleurer wirft den Ball hoch in der Hoffnung, er kommt nicht runter. Ja. Und dann kommt er runter und denkt sich, jetzt muss ich ihn nochmal hochwerfen. Man kann sich nicht fallen lassen, das sind sehr teure Jonglierbälle und der Boden ist Lava. Aber man wirft ihm mehr Jonglierbälle zu und du struggelt immer mehr und bist wieder auf dem Einrad auch. Ist ja die Frage, ob wenn Menschen auf anderen Planeten irgendwann leben, mit anderen Schwerkraftverhältnissen, ob dann die Kunst des Jonglierens entweder komplett aufblüht, stell dir vor, Jonglage mit einem Drittel der Schwerkraft auf der Erde, oder es einfach zu einer Farce wird. Ja, es wird einfach lächerlich. Weil jeder jonglieren kann, wenn die Schwerkraft nicht so stark ist. Aber auch gut, wenn man dann auf dem Mond üben kann, so als Trainingscamp, Jongnage-Trainingscamp. Das ist auch nicht schlecht, genau. Dass man sagt, du willst wirklich auf dem Saturn jonglieren. Dann musst du ja erst mal Venus, Mond und Pluto anfangen. Genau. Und dann geht's los. Mond ist erstmal entspannt, da kann man schön anfangen zu trainieren. Ja, da sind die Kinder. Langsam fallen sie hoch, fliegen sie wieder runter. Genau, du hast dann auch auf deinem Jonglieranzug diese Abzeichen. Mondabzeichen habe ich gemacht, Venusabzeichen habe ich gemacht, Saturn
fehlt mir noch. Ich bin Luna-Jongleur.
Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Vielleicht auch ein
weirdes Comeback des Sailor Moon-Franchises,
die dann alle hier
jonglieren können halt einfach. Nicht mehr das,
also was auch zur Hölle sie sonst
in den Folgen machen. Tatsächlich
habe ich immer wieder Lust, mir mal so Folgen
von solchen Serien anzugucken, weil ich mir beim
besten Willen nicht erklären kann, was da der Plot ist von der Folge Sailor Moon. Die sind ja 20 Minuten lang, 25 Minuten lang. Ja, aber selbst da brauchst du ja einen Anfang, Mitte und Ende. Genau. Und über hunderte Folgen. Was machen die denn? Ich finde das lang. Auch diese Serie The Kickers, The Kickers, The Kickers, weiß ich nicht, ob das der Name war, aber wo ja von einem Fussballspiel die Idee war. Oder hier auch so eine Basketballmannschaft.
Ja, da hängt der Fussballspiel, das hat eine Dramaturgie. Oh, Erzfeind, Rivale, es geht los, wir liegen hinten. Oh nein, wir müssen stürmen.
Aber über 19 Staffeln, 30 Folgen, eine Stunde.
Ja, aber die vierte Staffel war ja ein Schuss einfach nur.
Über die vierte Staffel wollen wir hier nicht reden, die war eine Farce.
Ja, die war eine Farce. Die war wie Jonglieren am Mond.
Ich habe letztens mir sogar den Aufwand gemacht, mal eine Folge Thomas the Tank Engine anzuschauen. Weil ich mir wirklich nicht verstehen konnte, wie eine Folge aussieht. Weil die immer auch auf Gleisen sind. Die sind auf Gleisen unterwegs. Wo du denkst so, oh nein, Hilfe, da wird, Ronny wird entführt. Wir müssen ihm helfen. Du, ich bin leider auf dem falschen Gleis. Ich komme da nicht hin. Ich bin auf einem Gleis. Können wir die Weichen, können wir die Weichen, nee, ich muss jetzt eh los, weil mein Leben ist fremdbestimmt, von dem Fahrplan. Und von dem dicken Kontrolleur. Von dem dicken Kontrolleur. Immer dicke Kontrolleur, wird immer dicker Kontrolleur genannt. Einziger Mensch bei Thomas der Lokomotive. Ja, und interessante Figur, wie die Menschheit sich darstellt, den Zügen, die ja einerseits Schöpfer, aber auch Gängelmeister ist. Gängelmann. Und im Grunde, wenn ich es euch ersparen kann, die meisten Folgen beinhalten das Problem, dass irgendeine Lokomotive einen Hügel nicht hochkommt und eine andere Lokomotive aushelfen muss und die hochschieben muss. Und das ist 80 Prozent des Plots.
Da gibt es sogar eine Lokomotive, und das ist eine der erstaunlichsten Unterhaltungsmachwerke der letzten 500 Jahre meiner Meinung nach.
Es gibt diese, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Zug heißt, aber es ist eine, die dritte oder vierte Folge, und der hat keine Lust mehr.
Der will nicht mehr fahren, der sagt, ich habe keinen Bock mehr.
Völlig nachvollziehbare Reaktionen für die Lokomotive, die sagt, ich muss Sachen ziehen.
Will ich nicht.
Will ich nicht mehr.
Bleibt stehen.
Und das ist ein die den ein. Warum? Der bleibt unter einer Brücke stehen, weil es ihm da gefällt, da ist Schatten und da bleibt er stehen. Dann sagen die, dann mauern wir jetzt die Brücke zu, den Tunnel zu. Aber wo widerspricht das deinem Plan? Erstmal nicht wirklich. An welchem Punkt sagt er, seid ihr bescheuert? Weil ihm ist ja egal, er will nicht mehr fahren. Naja, das ist ja so ein bisschen so, wenn dein Kind Zigarette raucht, muss es die ganze Schachtel rauchen. Du willst alleine sein, dann wirst du jetzt eingemauert. Also du bestrafst ihn nicht mit dem Gegenteil, sondern gibst ihm noch mehr, damit er sieht, dass das, was er will, weil ihm damit zu bestrafen, was er will, tut ja viel mehr weh, als mit dem, was er nicht will. Wer mauert ihn ein? Andere Menschen. Andere Menschen? Andere Menschen mauern ihn ein. Gerade war der dicke Kontrolleur noch der einzige Mensch. Keine weiteren Fragen. Und am Ende der Folge gibt es ja immer so eine kleine Moral. Und da heißt es dann auch, findet ihr, dass das gerechtfertigt ist? Ich schon. Tschüss, bis nächste Woche, macht's gut. Ciao. Ganz, ganz strange Serie. Und ist er noch mehrere Folgen horizontal. Wird es horizontal auch ein bisschen erzählt, oder ist er in der nächsten Folge sitcomartig wieder frei? Geht schon so ein bisschen weiter. Ir will der dann doch wieder raus und wird rausgemauert und dann ist er aber rostig oder so. Ich glaube, es ging um Rost, dass der irgendwie sich abwaschen soll, keine Ahnung genau, es ist halt wirklich sehr limitiert. Ja, apropos Züge, wir waren ja in Bochum bei Star Express und ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir letzte Folge nicht drüber reden konnten. Na, na, na, na, na, crazy. Es war unfassbar. Weil, also, ehrlich gesagt, vielen Dank nochmal an die liebe Einladung. Durch unsere Musical-Folge war es uns möglich, da zu erscheinen, zur Wiederaufnahme nach der Gönner. Wir haben es geschafft, in den sehr kleinen, aber sehr exklusiven Kreis der Musical-Obrigkeit in Deutschland aufzusteigen. Wir haben Gönner.
Wir haben Gönner, es gibt Gönnertum, wir wurden eingeladen und also ich als jemand, der natürlich auch im Ruhrgebiet aufgewachsen ist und dadurch auch mit dem Styler Express aufgewachsen ist, war das für mich ein bisschen ein Stück weit auch heimkommen. Ja, das hat man dir auch angemerkt. Du warst emotional den Abend über, du hattest das Funkeln eines
zwölfjährigen Jungen in den Augen, nochmal die Züge sehen, die Sprünge. Ich war zu Hause, ich bin wieder zu Hause angekommen und so. Das war wie, wie sind dann alles Kinderzimmer nochmal zu kommen und diesen Geruch im Kinderzimmer nochmal aufzunehmen. Nostalgie pur. Ich habe aber auch versucht, das Ganze mit frischen Augen zu sehen, weil neben mir sei es ja der Florentin, der noch nie weder die Geschichte von Star-Express kannte, noch als Kind mal im Star-Express war. Ich bin im bayerischen Bergeland aufgewachsen, ich kenne die Krampal und das war's an Unterhaltung einmal im Jahr geschlagen werden von maskierten Männern, das war meine Form der Unterhaltung, die ich aus Bayern kenne und jetzt plötzlich komme ich hier. Auch nicht schlecht. Ne, ist super. Wollen wir nicht werten. Können wir auch gerne mal zusammen machen. Jetzt komme ich in den Norden und jetzt heißt es ja plötzlich, wir haben ja eine Show mit Sängern auf Rollschuhen. So genau, deswegen ist ja, du kennst ja auch andere Musicals. Du bist ja prinzipiell zugänglich für die Kunst vom Musical. Ja. So und deswegen, das heißt, der Part, der war eher, war klar, das wirst du zu schätzen wissen und einzuordnen wissen. Aber jetzt ist man dann in der Show mit Gleisen, die ins Publikum gehen und Menschen auf Rollschuhen, die im weirden Kostüm Züge darstellen und darüber singen, dass sie Züge sind. Und jetzt bist du da als erwachsener Mann zum ersten Mal drin. und es hat mich, ehrlich gesagt, noch mehr an den Armen gefesselt, immer wieder rechts rüber zu gucken, in deine verwirrten Augen, die immer kleiner und zweifelnder wurden und what the hell mässiger wurden. Es ist nichts Schöneres als ohne Erwartungen in diese Show zu gehen. Ich war erst mal hin und weg, als ich die Bühne gesehen habe. Weil das ist ja so eine spezial angefertigte Bühne mit so Bahnen durchs Publikum, wo die fahren. Und ich habe ja schon gehört, okay, Musical auf Rollschuhe, dachte ich mir, gut, die fahren halt da von links nach rechts. Aber nein, die fahren halt da quer durchs Publikum, oben mehrere Ebenen und so, total abgefahren. Und es war grossartig, sich darauf einzulassen und der Story zu folgen. So, weil jetzt an einem gewissen Punkt, ich als Kind, du siehst ein Rennen, du siehst Locks, du die singen, es gibt Livemusik, es ist laut, viele Effekte, amazing, bester Tag des Jahres. Ja, als Erwachsener setzt man sich ja auch hin und will der Story folgen und hört den Texten zu.
Und wenn man als Erwachsener zum ersten Mal das sieht, dachte ich, ich musste die ganze
Zeit lachen, weil ich dachte, das ist das weirdeste Erlebnis für dich, deines Lebens
wahrscheinlich.
Es war sehr strange.
Vor allem, es war natürlich eine doppelte Weirdness-Situation, weil wir haben ja die
überarbeitete Version gesehen.
Also das war generell erst mal die erste Show nach dem Lockdown, deswegen war aber
auch der Bürgermeister von Bochum da und hat eine Rede gehalten und toll und Nachricht von Andrew Lloyd Werner. Genau, alle waren dabei und alles grossartig und es war ja die überarbeitete Version, die schon vor dem Lockdown überarbeitet wurde. Also Bürgermeister ist ja auch der beste, was macht ein Bürgermeister außer genau sowas. Ich dachte mir, es wird, Style Express wieder aufgenommen, Bürgermeister spricht kurz, that's his job, das macht er. Und mit so grossen Scheren Baumärkte aufmachen, das war es. Grossartig, grossartig. Oder den neuen Zug einweihen. Ich glaube, als Bürgermeister hast du eh viel mit Zügen zu tun, seit der Style Express, neuer Zug, neuer Bahnhof, neuer Aufzug am Bahnhof, neue Bude am Bahnhof. Aufzug, Abzug. Durchzug, alles, ich habe damit zu tun. Star-Express ist mein Ding. Es war eine grossartige Nachricht von Andrew Lloyd Webber, der einem auch nochmal die Absurdität vor Augen führt, dass das ja eine amerikanische Produktion ist, wo das einzige Theater, wo dieses Stück noch nach der Originalvorstellung mit diesen Bahnen aufgeführt werden kann, in Bochum ist. Ja, genau. Also irgendwie in Deutschland hat man sich gesagt, Züge, wir lieben Züge, Storys sind uns eher egal. Also wenn wir ankreuzen müssten, wäre es bei Sophia eher egal. Und wir lieben aber auch diese Lightshow, wir lieben diesen industriellen Charakter. Ich finde, da hat es auch in Bochum eine sehr gute Stadt für gefunden irgendwie. Absolut, weil Züge haben ja wenig Glamour eigentlich, aber du schaffst es ja durch diesen Starlight Express, eine der Figuren, die ich noch nicht verstanden habe, so eine Art Gottfigur. Don't question it, das ist ein großer Fehler gewesen, danach auch noch ein Auto. Aber der Starlet Express ist irgendwie so eine Art über alles hinweggehende Fantasie.
Wie gesagt, ich finde noch ein Auto. Aber der Starlet Express ist irgendwie so eine Art über alles hinweggehende Fantasie. Wie gesagt, ich finde es auch doof, dass du das jetzt über erklärst. Und es war auf jeden Fall interessant, weil um die Story ganz kurz zusammenzufassen, unser Protagonist ist eine Dampflok. Ja. Und natürlich seht ihr da schon vielleicht die Problematik, dass die Dampflok eine veraltete Technologie ist. Denn es gibt mittlerweile viel neuere
und modernere Technologien,
wie zum Beispiel die Diesellok.
Die moderne Technologie der Diesellok.
Und völlig aus dem Cyberspace,
aus der Zukunft zu uns gereist,
die Elektro-Lok.
Was ich liebe, also das ist das,
Music kommt ja aus den 80ern,
so Ende der 80er, also keine Ahnung, Mitte der 80er wurde es gestartet und so.
Elektrizität und E-Züge waren da schon ein fucking Thing.
Ja. Und am Anfang stellen sich alle Züge vor. Ich meine, um kurz nochmal einzuleiten, das Ganze spielt in einem Traum von einem Kind, was sehr viel mit Zügen gespielt hat. Soll er ins Bett gehen? Mama, ich will doch nicht ins Bett. Doch, du gehst ins Bett, aber ich will das große Rennen spielen. Nein, es ist ins Bett. Licht geht aus und Kind sagt, heute Nacht ist das große Rennen und stellt dann die Züge vor, die es besitzt. Rusty, die Dumpflock, ist die älteste Zug, das war der erste Zug, den er bekommen hat. Damit fing alles an. Ich habe noch lange über alles nachgedacht, dazu gleich mehr. Weil wir kommen noch zum Ende des ganzen Dingen. So, und dann aber die E-Lock, dann stellt er alle Züge vor und alle kommen und plötzlich geht die Bühne so aus und dann kommt die gefährliche, crazy E-Lock, die singt, wie sie mit jedem Schlag Menschen umbringen kann, weil Elektrizität fucking gefährliche Zauberwerke ist. Zauber-S in Acht, die kommt die E-Log, das ist die krasseste, gefährlichste Lok, unberechenbar. Aber das hat in den 80ern, also ich meine, allein die Scheinwerfer im Theater und so weiter, alles in dem Theater sagt, Elektrizität ist handelbar. We got it. Ja, auch in deiner Tasche gibt dir einen Hint. Ja, wir kriegen das in die E-Gitarre, die gerade spielt. Wir kriegen das, we got it. Wir kriegen das hin, wir schaffen das, wir haben es gebändigt. Und dann trotzdem ist noch der Böse. Er ist grossartig und es gibt dann am Ende das grosse Rennen, wo Rusty als Dampflok natürlich Angst hat, dass sie verliert, aber was mich auch da weiter verwirrt, also vor allem, du hast ja dann nicht nur diese Geschwindigkeitsproblematik, dass die Dampflok nicht mithalten kann, sondern du hast ja auch in der neu überarbeiteten Version ja auch Anspielungen wie du mit deiner Dampflok, du verbrennst ja Kohle und CO2 und das wollen wir ja nicht. Wo man sich denkt, okay, unser Protagonist ist die veraltete Technologie, die sogar aktiv als moralisch verwerflicht vom Musical selbst dargestellt wird. Wie soll diese Geschichte enden? Und die E-Lock, die beste Technologie, wurde als Bösewicht etabliert. Einerseits als Bösewicht, aber andererseits natürlich für den Zuschauer, checkt man, aber die Dampflok ist ja auch keine Alternative. Die Dampflok Rusty wird außerdem von einem jungen Darsteller gespielt, was mich völlig verwirrt hat. Die veraltete Technologie hat eigentlich in der Geschichte her eigentlich eine der jüngsten Charaktere. Greaseball als Diesel-Lokomotive ist älter, und dieser weirde Cyberspace-Elektra-Zug ist auch älter. Also Rusty ist die älteste, veraltetste Technologie mit der jüngsten Figur, der Zuschauer soll die Sympathien dafür hegen, weiß aber, die kann nicht gewinnen, weil uns das Stück auch sagt, Dieseldampf ist veraltet. Und ich dachte mir wirklich als interessant, Moment mal, wie endet jetzt diese Geschichte? Wie kriegen wir das irgendwie hin? Weil Rusty kann nicht gewinnen, er ist die veraltete Technologie, das wäre auch die Botschaft, wäre auch super strange. Also die Kinder, die da drin sitzen mit einem, was zur Hölle ist, eine Dampflok-Blick. Wie gesagt, die Kinder kriegen fucking Fistbombs und High-Fives von den Darstellern, die um die herumfahren und haben den besten Tag des Lebens. Ich verstehe nicht, wie du das immer in Frage stellen kannst. Hast du den kleinen Jungen, der lustigweise direkt vor uns saß, gesehen, der wirklich, und am Ende hat er von so einem Kastenwagen, Frachtwagen, hat der einen Fistbomb bekommen. Und hast du diese leuchtenden Augen gesehen? Das ist eigentlich das Schönste, einem Kind zuzuschauen, der das Stück anschaut. Das ist viel besser, als das Stück anzuschauen. Noch besser ist, dir zuzugucken, wie du das Stück hast. Erwachsene, die es zum ersten Mal sehen zu zukünftig, ist das Beste. Und für alle, die es nicht wissen und sich fragen, wie geht denn dieses Stück aus? Ja, geht rein. Wie macht man denn diese Widerspruch, wie löst man den auf? Und am Ende gibt es das große Rennen. Rusty gewinnt und es gibt einen großen Song. Dampf, Dampf, Dampf ist das Beste, Dampf ist die Zukunft. Und so endet das Stück. Und Diesel nimmt, also der Song beginnt. Nicht ganz klar. Davor sagen sie sowas wie, jetzt ist mir alles scheißegal oder sowas. Dann singen sie, die ersten Zeilen sind, Diesel nimmt dir deinen Glauben, Elektrizität schafft's nie. Dampf allein ist jetzt die Kraft, die uns jetzt vorwärts zieht, es gibt ein Licht ganz am Ende des Tonwells. Das ist der Song, der gesungen wird. Dampf allein ist jetzt die Kraft, den uns jetzt weiss. Also am Ende gewinnt Dampf und alle sind happy und man versteht nicht genau warum. Das Ding ist ja, ich bin mit dem alten Sub- gross geworden, da hat die Story meines Erachtens noch ein bisschen mehr Sinn ergeben, weil das war kein Thema, die Kraft war nicht so Thema. Also es war immer klar so, das ist die nette Lok, die zu allen nett ist und die Mut hat und so und es war die klassische Heldenreise von dem Underdog, der gewinnt. Das habe ich nicht hinterfragt. Jetzt, wo das Musical das anfängt zu kommentieren, dass es aber diese verbotene Dreckskraft ist, die unsere Welt in den Abgrund treibt, verstehe ich nicht ganz, warum es noch gewinnt. Aber es musste überarbeitet werden, denn das habe ich auch schon mal, glaube ich, von ein paar hundert Folgen gesagt, dass es mir wieder eingefallen ist, dass damals die ganzen Loks waren Männer und die ganzen Wagen waren Frauen. Und die Frauen hatten sogar einen Sonder darüber, dass sie nicht vorwärts kommen ohne Mann. Also sehr problematisch, wenn ich sehr problematisch. Und deswegen verstehe ich schon, dass man da jetzt einer Geschichte geschraubt hat. Moment mal. Man hat es aber auch nicht in den Griff bekommen. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Weil mittlerweile ist es so, dass es sowohl weibliche als auch männliche Loks gibt. Es gab damals auch schon männliche Wagen. Okay, und jetzt auch weibliche und männliche Waggons. Und die Waggons haben jetzt auch so einen Song, ich brauche niemanden, ich komme alleine in der Welt zurecht. Dadurch, dass aber beide Parteien Geschlechter gemischt sind, ergibt der Song ja auch überhaupt gar keinen Sinn mehr, weil es dann ja gar keine Aussage mehr über Geschlechter ist, sondern es tatsächlich über Waggons geht. Und man jetzt hier als Zuschauer ein Lied hört mit Wir Waggons, wir brauchen niemanden, wir kommen alleine zurecht. Und man denkt sich, mehr brauche ich nicht. Und man sitzt im Publikum und denkt, ja okay, dann zeig mir Waggon. Genau, hier geht es nicht um Geschlechterrollen, ob wir es lieben. Ja, absolut. Okay, Waggon, dann zeig mir mal, wie du jetzt von A nach B kommst. Plötzlich haben wir hier nicht mehr ein gesellschaftliches Problem, sondern ein Ingenieurproblem. Wir haben einfach ein fucking physikalisches von A nach B Problem. Er sagt, die Wagen sind selbstbestimmt. Es ergibt gar keinen Sinn mehr. Null. An keinem Punkt kann man aus diesem Müssengegen sagen, ja, das ist eine schöne Botschaft. ist ganz, ganz krude. Aber auch ganz merke ich mich immer diese übergeordnete Position des Jungen, der auch immer wieder reinspricht und sagt, so jetzt ist das Rennen. Manchmal widersprechen die Züge auch dem Jungen und sagen so, nee. Am Ende haben sie gesagt, so das war es jetzt. Das war nämlich am Ende, da haben sie ihn über Bord geworfen, den Jungen. Was auch verwahnsinnig ist, weil wir sind Teil der Fantasie des Jungen. Der Jungen belebt seine Spielzeugzüge mit Leben und gibt denen Charaktereigenschaften und spielt mit denen. Die wiederum widersetzen sich ihm aber in seiner Fantasie. Also in der Fantasie fantasiert der Junge, dass die jetzt ein Eigenleben bekommen und ihn nicht mehr brauchen. Es ist absolut absurd. Es ist wirklich absurd. Ich dachte am Ende so, ah, okay, wir sprechen ihm jetzt, seine Eltern sagen ihm sowas wie, ah, nee, die Dampflok darf nicht gewinnen und so, es ist schlechte Technologie und so, und ich habe es am Ende so verstanden, dass die ihm quasi auch selber raten, nee, hier geht es um Spielzeuge, und Drusty war sein ältestes Spielzeug, vor allem habe ich da ein bisschen zu viel reininterpretiert jetzt, aber es ist ein ältestes
Spielzeug, damit hat alles angefangen
und er will die halt gewinnen lassen.
Ich hab nicht,
also außer wahnsinnig viel
Adrenalin konnte ich nicht viel mitnehmen
aus dem Abend, inhaltlich, aber grossartige
Show. Natürlich
wurde der Abend auch noch mal
in einem anderen Licht für uns interessant, weil wir ja im Februar dort auftreten. Genau, also im Prinzip war der ganze Abend ein crazy what the fuck is happening, oh fuck, hier treten wir auf, oh nein, oh nein, oh nein. Und wir haben keine hundert Lichter und Rollschuhe dabei, sondern wir sind Steffi und Flori, die auf der Bühne stehen mit diesen weirden Bahnen überall. Also es wird abgefahren. Ziehen wir uns Inliner an? Ich weiß nicht, ich bin nicht so gut auf Inlinern, muss ich sagen. Ich würde gerne Fahrrad nehmen, wenn das okay ist mit den Sicherheitsbeschränkungen. Boosterboard und Fahrrad ist auch okay, finde ich völlig okay. Guck mal, wir sind die neue Geschichte, wir interpretieren das Stück nochmal neu um mit Fahrrad und Boosted Board.
Ich finde es sehr gut, wenn wir sehr viele Fahrräder hätten. Ihr bringt alle eure Fahrräder mit, die nach Bochum kommen. Dann machen wir den Kampf E-Scooter gegen Boosted Board, gegen E-Mobilität, gegen Fahrrad, gegen E-Fahrrad. Dann gucken wir mal, wer am Ende die grossen Rennen gewinnt. Aber was für ein Wider-Junger auch, der das dann träumt. Mama, ich will noch ein bisschen mit meinem Modell-E-Auto
und mit dem E-Fahrrad spielen.
Nee, du gehst jetzt schlafen, du Weirdo.
Fucking Sicko.
Ach, es ist großartig, es war ein sehr, sehr schöner Abend.
Fast schon ein wundervoller Abend, möchte ich sagen.
Es war voller Wunder, wir hatten sehr viel Spaß.
Vielen, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Und vielen, vielen Dank für alle Leute, die uns geantwortet haben auf unseren Aufruf, schickt uns eure Wunder. Oh, Wundertime! Der Moment, wo Stefan alles vergessen hat. Und jetzt kommt wieder alles zurück. Wir haben letzte Woche über Wunder gesprochen und haben gesagt, wir brauchen neue Wunder, wir brauchen neue Heilige, schickt uns eure Wunder. Was wir euch nicht gesagt haben, ist, dass wir die Wunder jetzt alle für uns selber nehmen, beim Vatikan einreichen und damit neue Heilige werden. Ich habe sehr viel Ärger bekommen, dass ich immer Vatikan gesagt habe. Du hast immer Vatikan gesagt und es ist Vatikan. Wie hart kann man die Botschaft Gottes falsch verstehen, dass es darum geht, wie man es richtig ausspricht.
Und zwar,
ganz fantastisch, habe ich ein paar Wunder geschickt bekommen. Genau, erstmal ging es
ja auch darum, zu sagen,
wir prüven das
Wunder. Genau. In einem True Crime
artigen Podcast-Folge
würden wir gerne eure Wunder
auf Hieb- und Stichfestigkeit
überprüfen, ob das alles
so passiert ist. Ja. Wenn es wasserdicht ist und ihr wirklich heilig seid, würden wir das einreichen im Vatikan. Genau, es gibt nämlich tatsächlich Miracle-Busters vom Vatikan, die dann irgendwo hinfahren und das überprüfen, weil ich glaube, du brauchst mindestens zwei bestätigte Wunder, um heiliger zu werden. Deswegen versuchen wir dann natürlich, was einzureichen. Wir haben eine Nachricht bekommen von jemandem, dessen Namen
ich vergessen hat und der meinte, er wurde geblitzt
und hat aber nie einen Brief bekommen.
Unfassbar, unfassbares
Wunder. Müsste man natürlich
rekonstruieren, was da passiert ist.
Lass uns das in Detailgetreue
rekonstruieren, was da passiert ist. Inwiefern der Heilige Geist
da eingegriffen hat, also ob er dann
irgendwie in die Linse geflogen ist,
ob er den Film vernichtet hat,
also was genau ist passiert
oder ob der Brief verloren gegangen
Vielen Dank. eingegriffen hat, also ob er dann irgendwie in die Linse geflogen ist, ob er den Film vernichtet hat, also was genau ist passiert,
oder ob der Brief verloren gegangen ist,
oder ob der Postbote von einem Blitz
getroffen wurde, kurz bevor er den
in den Briefkasten legen konnte. Also da muss
man natürlich jetzt ins Detail gehen. Genau,
finde ich, da sollte man richtig doll ins Detail gehen
oder nach einem anderen Wunder suchen.
Vielleicht das Wunder von Richard.
Der schreibt ein Wunder, das schon einige Jahre her ist. Okay. Aus dem Jahre 2014. Nicht so lange her. Ich war als Dozent der Universität Osnabrück angestellt. In unserem Institut hatten wir einige Briefkästen mit unseren Namen darauf. Viele Postwunder, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Wunder, ja. Eines Tages mache ich meinen Briefkasten auf und finde etwas darin. Die komplette Videospielsammlung der Far Cry-Reihe für die Xbox 360. Zu dem Zeitpunkt war die Konsole in meinem Besitz. Bis heute konnte ich mir nicht erklären, wer diese Videospiele dort hineingeworfen hat. Ich habe eine E-Mail an alle MitarbeiterInnen und all meine StudentInnen geschrieben, allerdings ohne Erfolg. Es lag auch keine Nachricht dabei. Ich hatte auch mal die Theorie, dass ich vielleicht die Spieler hätte durchspielen müssen, um eine geheime Nachrichtsschreie zu schreiben. Sie sind aber nicht mehr in meinem Besitz. Also dass sie verschenkt, dass sie weiter verschenkt. Und jetzt kriegen wir noch eine andere E-Mail, wo auch jemand so fucking Far Cry Sachen bekommt. Das ist ja das Tolle an Wundern, man kann sie weitergeben. Und die Far Cry Spielreihe für die Xbox 360 einfach weitergegeben. Okay, also das finde ich schon ein besseres Wunder. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob wir damit wirklich in Rom vor dem Papst. Ich weiß nicht, ob Far Cry Teil des erweiterten christlichen Kanons ist. Ich kenne die Spielreihe nicht gut. Ich habe meins gespielt und ich bin mir sicher, dass es es nicht ist. Okay, gut, da kannst du das besser einschätzen. Aber vielleicht, Gott wirkt ja in mysteriösen Weisen. Gottes Wege sind unergründlich. Und hier vielleicht nur mit der kompletten Far Cry-Reihe für den Dozenten aus Osnabrück. Also interessante Geschichte auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt aber auch nicht so richtig das Wunder, was man gesucht hat, oder?
Es ist schon ein Wunder, ich finde es schon fantastisch.
Es ist ein Wunder, das war es auch tatsächlich.
Also das sind alle Wunder, die wir geschickt bekommen haben.
Jesus fucking Christ, es ist wirklich nicht mehr das Elbe.
Also damit müssen wir jetzt die Pilgerreise antreten, gen Süden, um die Wunder einzureichen.
Aber was wir auch bekommen haben als Nachricht.
Moment, ganz kurz, das war's?
Das war's.
Leute, hört uns doch irgendwer, was ist, aber das spreche ich auch ein bisschen meine Theorie, dass Deutschland kein Wunderland ist.
Nee.
Hier ist alles so durchgerechnet, durchkalkuliert, durchpragmatisiert.
Hier ist wenig Platz mehr für Wunder.
Es gibt aber einen Ort in Deutschland für Wunder.
Das Kernwasser Wunderland Kalkar.
Ja, da erzähle ich ihr jede Woche von.
Da hat uns nämlich Ellen geschrieben.
Und Ellen ist niemand Geringeres
als
Kerni. Nein!
Kerni? Ellen ist Kerni.
Nein, du bist Kerni! Das Maskottchen
des Wunderland,
des Kernwasser Wunderlandes
Kalkar. Ja, davon habe ich ja gesprochen.
Und es ist unfassbar, und sie schreibt,
es ist auf jeden Fall nicht zu empfehlen.
Als Maskottchen arbeiten kann ich ihr nicht empfehlen, man schwitzt sich bei 30 Grad im Sommer zu Tode und der Kopf ist einfach super schwer. Und das Schlimmste daran ist, wie die anderen Menschen darum dich behandeln. Und aber auch interessant fand ich, anscheinend hat Kerni auch noch eine Frau. Seine Frau heißt übrigens Kerna und für sie hatten wir auch ein Kostüm, das wurde dann immer ausgepackt, wenn Cairney zu doll gestunken hat.
Also diese Glamour-Welt der Maskottchen wird hier relativ gut entzaubert von Ellen.
Ja, Moment, aber das ist jetzt für mich ein Wunder. Das ist mein persönliches Wunder heute. Okay.
Weil ich habe das Kernwasserwunder geliebt, ich meine, das ist so ein Off-Brand-B-Freizeitpark, machen wir uns nichts vor.
Weißt du auch, liebes Cairney?
Ganz kurz nochmal erklären, das ist ein altes Atomkraftwerk.
Richtig, stillgelegt und da ist jetzt ein Freizeitpark rumgebaut mit dem Maskottchen Kerney. Das heißt Kernwasser Wunderland. Und es klingt schon so, als ob man da nicht so viel Zeit verbringen sollte. Es klingt so, als ob man da maximal eine Viertelstunde sein sollte. Und dann ist denn Kerney auch ein strahlenderutzanzug? Das ist meine Frage, glaube ich.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der eigentliche Grund. Aber so wie sie es hier das Kostüm zeigt, hat Kerni drei Finger. Was ich nicht ideal finde für ein Maskottchen, das einem wahrscheinlich die Angst vor radioaktiven Strahlen nehmen sollte, wenn man sagt, hey, wir sind in einem alten Kernkraftwerk. Das schafft der Freizeitpark sowieso nicht. Es sieht so aus wie Tschernobyl, dieser Freizeitpark, den es ja auch gibt, der stillgelegte. Ne, der hat in der Nähe auch von dem Atomkraftwerk. Ach so, ach so. Und so sieht der auch ein bisschen aus, ist aber noch in Betrieb. Nein, ich liebe es kein Wasserwunderland. Und niemand weiß, was Kerney sein soll. Es sieht so ein bisschen aus wie ein Oranger Dinosaurier vielleicht oder irgend so eine Art. Ja, da ist viel reingegangen, also so viel. Es ist auf jeden Fall so ein postapokalyptisches Wesen. Also grossartig tatsächlich, jetzt wo du es sagst, ist das ein Wunder, dass du vom Wunderwasserland Kernkraftwerk erzählst und das Maskottchen uns zuhört und uns schreibt. Vielen Dank an Alan, ist auf jeden Fall eine grossartige Nachricht, freut uns sehr. Das mit dem Wechseln, Kostümwechsel bei Gestank kann ich nur nachvollziehen. Ich war am Wochenende nämlich auf Schloss Burg, habe eine Burg besichtigt, es hat ein tolles Museum da auch in der Nähe von Wermelskirchen, toll und da hat der Teufel die Burg gebaut und der Erste, der über die Zugbrücke muss, waren Huhn und die Fledermaus ist dann in die Hölle gekommen. Und dann habe ich da ein bisschen was über Mittelalter gelernt und es war nämlich so, dass die meisten, und das fand ich unglaublich lustig, die oft hatten die eine Zweitburg. Kennt man ja auch von Hell der Ringe. Die Leute von Ronrohan hatten ja auch Helmsklamm, wo sie dann auch mal hingegangen sind im Kriegsfall. Wie dem auch sei, die Leute von Schlossburg hatten auch noch eine B-Burg irgendwo. Und immer wenn eine Burg zu sehr gestunken hat, weil die haben halt ihr Fäkalienproblem nicht in den Griff bekommen, sind die gewechselt. Ach was. Die haben ihre Burg abandoned, weil es zu sehr gestunken hat. Die haben es dann nicht mehr ausgehalten. Und sind dann als ganze Burggemeinschaft haben die andere Burg bezogen, die sie oft hatten. Wahnsinn. Und dann dachte ich mir, eigentlich bist du ja als, wenn du jetzt ein Kriegsvolk bist, was nicht kriegen kann, aber sehr gut im Hygiene ist, so ein Sagrotanvolk, dann kannst du ja einfach Burgen einnehmen, diese leeren Burgen. Ach so, ja, ja, während die verlassen sind, das stimmt schon. Diese Stinkeburgen. Aber Wahnsinn, vor allem wer hat diese Entscheidung getroffen? Also ich kenne das ja auch, meine Wohnung müllt ja auch regelmäßig zu, aber es ist halt ein fliessender Übergang. Es ist jetzt nie so der Punkt, wo ich sage, so ab jetzt ist es unerträglich, sondern es ist so ein schleichender Prozess. Wer entscheidet da? Ja, da möchte ich dich fragen, wann schneidest du denn deine Fingernägel? Sehr guter Punkt. Sehr guter Punkt. Einmal die Woche, immer Mittwoch. Ja, aber, ach so. Ja, also entweder haben die das klare Datum, oder aber, wie ich meine Finger geschneide, an irgendeinem Punkt sage ich, das geht jetzt zu lang. Ja. Von jetzt auf gleich macht das Nächste jetzt zu lang. Ja, stimmt. Von einer Sekunde auf die nächste, ja. Aber das wächst ja auch gleichmäßig. Aber du hast ja gerade in so einer Burg unterschiedliche Ansprüche. Und vor allem wahrscheinlich auch die Niederen leben irgendwie weiter unten, wo alles hingebracht wird und die hohen Herren. Vielleicht gibt es da wirklich einen, der es entscheiden muss. Dann sind die einfach umgezogen. Das ist schon krass. Aber dann, wenn sie dann wieder zurückkamen, war es dann auch wieder okay, oder was? Ich glaube, es muss halt einfach, glaube ich, wortwörtlich ein bisschen Gras über die Sache wachsen. Wahnsinn. Das ist so, das ist so, das ist so eklig. Ich kann mir vor allem auch immer nicht vorstellen, was das für ein Riesenaufwand gewesen sein muss, so eine Burg zu bauen. Vor allem viele Burgen sind ja auch oben auf Bergen oder so drauf. Und ich denke, wie habt ihr das geschafft? Und dann zu sagen, lass uns die gleiche Burg exakt so nochmal 100 Kilometer weiter weg bauen und dann da hinlaufen oder mit Skifahren oder was auch immer. Also wie sehr muss es gestunken haben, dass man sagt, diese Burg, die wir jetzt über 200 Jahre gebaut haben, die jetzt gerade mal perfekt ist, die lassen wir komplett leer zurück, weil wir halten es hier nicht mehr aus. Und deswegen ist es, glaube ich, Köln auch spannend als mittelalterliche Stadt, wo dann hier das Parfum ja miterfunden wurde. Das Eau de Cologne.
Gut, aber so eine ganze Burg, da brauchst du dann so einen Katapult mit so einem Eau de Cologne-Glasbehälter, wo du einmal die Burg feuerst, bevor du die einnimmst. Wie in dem Film Das Parfüm. Ich habe den nicht gesehen, aber das ist, glaube ich, die Story. Also schon krass. Und ich habe auch selber die Erfahrung gemacht, dass überraschenderweise finde ich, ist Geruch der Sinneseindruck, der einen am meisten kriegen kann, gegen den man nichts machen kann. Zum Beispiel musste ich ab und zu, ich hatte eine Mitbewohnerin, die hatte eine Katze und die hat manchmal in mein Bett gepinkelt. Und du kommst halt nach Hause, nachts irgendwie, Drehtag oder was, kommst nach Hause und du weißt, okay, die Katze hat in dein Bett gepinkelt.
Jetzt hast du zwei Optionen. Entweder du wechselst das jetzt alles, sprühst das ein, ich hatte da noch so ein antibakterielles Spray und so, aber alles ist nass oder es ist trocken, aber dafür stinkt es wie die Hölle. Und ich habe wirklich Experimente gemacht. Was ist schlimmer? Nasse Bettdecke, aber dafür riecht es halt nur nach diesem Spray oder trocken mit Katzenurin drin und du hast keine Chance in einem Bett zu schlafen, das stinkt. Wirklich, vergiss es. Du kannst schlafen, wenn es hell ist, wenn es laut ist, wenn es nass ist, geht alles. Unangenehm, aber geht. Aber du kannst nicht schlafen, wenn es stinkt. Es ist wirklich, du kannst auch nichts dagegen machen.
Und ich weiß nicht, warum, warum das gerade der Sinn ist, wo der Körper sagt,
nein, schlaf lieber gar nicht,
als wenn es so gestinkt.
Vielleicht ist es wirklich so schlimm
mit Krankheiten und Bakterien und so.
Das ist so the innermost
thing, dass halt, man sagt,
Säbelzahntiger haben
in die Höhle schon mal gepinkelt. Hier kannst du nicht schlafen, weil diese Höhle unsicher ist. Das ist, glaube ich, das. Ja, das kann schon sein. Deswegen bist du genau von Katzenurin. Weil ich denke mir immer so, es ist doch das Dümmste, was der Körper machen kann, ist nicht zu schlafen. Also die Schwelle für ab wann, sage ich, es ist besser nicht zu schlafen als X muss doch super hoch sein. Selbst wenn du Hunger hast, erschöpft bist und dir kalt ist und du Durst hast, ist es doch immer noch besser zu schlafen, als einfach wach die Nacht zu bleiben. Ja, jetzt bist du aber auch wenn du hast den Luxus, dass du als Mensch sehr gut schläfst und viel schläfst. Also ein Mensch, der wie du in Deutschland lebt, schläft ja wahrscheinlich mehr, als er körperlich muss. Weiß ich nicht. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Und deswegen glaube ich, wenn du jetzt drei Nächste wach gewesen wärst, hättest du wahrscheinlich in der vierten Nacht zu schlafen wie ein Baby, auch in einem nassen, vor Katzenpisse nassen Bett. Warum stinkt das denn so massiv? Warum, was hat es denn damit auch? Es ist der schlimmste Geruch der Welt, wirklich. Katzenurin ist absolut grauenvoll. Es ist schwer zu erklären, es hat so was super Beissendes, das geht durch den ganzen Körper und es ist wirklich richtig unangenehm. Wir haben eine sehr liebe Karte bekommen. Oh, mit den Bären drauf. Svenja, das ist eine sehr schöne Karte aus Finnland. Die ist richtig breit, die Karte, oder? Die ist eine fantastische, eine Cinemascope-Karte, eine richtig schöne, eine breite Karte. Und sie schickt uns heute die große Community-Folge. Wir machen mal ein bisschen Community-Content, mal gucken, was da kommt. Und diese Karte liegt ein bisschen länger bei mir rum, ich habe sie vergessen mitzubringen, kam aber auch erst vor ein paar Wochen an. Vielen Dank. Und zwar schreibt sie, dass sie in Finnland unterwegs ist und es sehr gut geht, dass sie uns da hört und das ihr ein bisschen Heimweh nimmt, dass sie mit ihrem Freund unterwegs ist und zeltet. Und dann hat sie noch geschrieben, dass sie uns ein kleines Urlaubsgedicht hat, hat sie uns noch geschrieben, und zwar in der Gedichtsform Elfchen, die ich komplett vergessen habe, wusste, dass sie existiert. Es geht um elf Wörter zu haben, aufgeteilt in verschiedenen Zeilen, und es ist eine ganz tolle Gedichtsform, und wie gesagt, sie ist zelten mit ihrem Freund in Finnland, und das ist ihr Gedicht. Verdauung. Grosses Thema. Ein Lochgraben. Menschen sind auch Tiere. Erleichternd. Genießt euren restlichen Sommer, passt auf ihr auf. Especially when the moths attack. Viel liebe Grüße, Svenja. Vielen Dank an Svenja, danke schön. Ich finde es ein sehr gutes Gedicht. Liebe Grüße an Finnland, finde ich auch gut. Ich finde es ein sehr gutes Gedicht und ich finde generell die Gedichte vom Elfchen toll. Ist ein bisschen das deutsche Haiku, ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten, Vergessung geraten. Lass uns das doch gerne wieder mal einführen. Warum nicht? Warum nicht? Schreib uns mal Elfchen. Und du darfst selber entscheiden, wie viele Wörter pro Zeile? Nein. Oder gibt es ein System? Wie ist die für eine deutsche Gedichtsform gehört? Ah ja, okay, gut, okay. Hat man klare Regeln. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich Einwort, zwei Wörter, drei Wörter, vier Wörter, Einwort oder sowas. Gleich geht es auch um Silben, weiß ich gerade nicht. Wir checken das nochmal, reichen es nach, aber lass uns Elfchen bitte wieder einführen als Gedichtsform. Und dann schickt uns doch mal Elfchen. Wir können natürlich auch, letzte Woche haben wir von unserer Erotik-Karriere gesprochen, wir wollen Erotik-Literatur schreiben, vielleicht können wir das ja kombinieren und ein Erotik-Elfchen schreiben. Also ein wirklich prickelndes, feuchtes, fröhliches Erotik-Elfchen. Das wäre das erste Erotik-Elfchen. Ich habe nämlich nicht so viel Angst vor Arbeit per se, nur, also Elfchen nimmt mir jegliche Angst, weil
am Ende hast du nur elf Wörter.
Die Fallhöhe ist auch nicht so hoch.
Selbst das beste Elfchen ist
nicht so gut. Still ein Elfchen.
Ja, Elfchen.
Genau, das meine ich. Deswegen ist es super, das machen wir mal.
Und auch da draußen, das können wir wieder einführen.
So Twitter ist mir auch mittlerweile einfach zu
Prosa-mäßig geworden.
Ist das die neue Social-Media-Plattform, wo du nur elf Wörter
hast pro Post?
Finde ich gar nicht schlecht, eine gute Idee.
Aber So Twitter ist mir auch mittlerweile einfach zu prosa-mässig geworden. Ist das die neue Social-Media-Plattform, wo du nur elf Wörter hast pro Post? Finde ich gar nicht schlecht, eine gute Idee. Also vielen Dank an Svenja nach Finnland. Finnland ist ein tolles Land, liegt aber leider nicht auf unserem Lieblingskontinent. Nein. Denn unser Lieblingskontinent ist immer noch Afrika! Und den schauen wir uns immer mal wieder an in unserer fantastischen beliebten Rubrik Antenne Afrika! Und in dieser Rubrik schickt ihr uns immer kleine Berichte, kleine Reportagen über verschiedene Länder Afrikas, denn Afrika ist kein Land, sondern Afrika besteht aus 55 Ländern, von denen wir schon einige kennengelernt haben und heute werden wir ein weiteres davon kennenlernen und zwar Djibouti. Djibouti, da hat uns die Conny einen Beitrag geschickt, die war vielleicht in Djibouti oder kennt sich damit gut aus, wir hören einfach mal rein, viel Spaß mit Conny und Djibouti. Bonjour, je m'appelle Costas et je raconte Djibouti à vous. Djibouti reiht sich neben Eritrea, Äthiopien und Somalia am Horn von Afrika ein und hat direkten Zugang zum Meer.
Neben der Hauptsprache Französisch, was ihr gerade gehört habt, finden sich vor allem Menschen, die Arabisch, Somali oder Afar sprechen.
Das drittkleinste Land Afrikas hat so einiges in sich.
Mein Team und ich wollen jetzt ein paar Eindrücke über Dschibuti mit euch teilen.
Proud, strong, anfangs zurückhaltender und dann immer offener, bunt, laut, beautiful, dusty, all-town vibe, känzerisch. All diese Worte beschreiben das Wesen der Menschen Djiboutis. Djiboutis Hauptstadt, die ich kennenlernen durfte, ist, leicht zu merken, Djibouti und kann innerhalb von 45 Minuten komplett umrundet werden.. Laut Wikipedia gilt sie mit durchschnittlichen 30 Grad Celsius als eine der heissesten Städte Afrikas. Laut, das ist ein gutes Stichwort. Muslimische Gebetsrufe, das ständige Hupen des Busses, getreu dem Motto Wer hupt hat Recht, oder das Stimmgewürr des Marktes holen einen beim entspannten Trinken einer Ananas-Fanta auf der Dachtarisse schnell ein und lenken von dem eigentlichen schönen Blick auf den Horizont ab. Denn als ehemalige französische Kolonie finden sich hier die schönste Architekturen und sanfte mediterrane Farbenspiele, bunte Gewänder, die bis zu den Knöcheln reichen, sind Kult, auch für Besucher. Dschipuitanerinnen lieben es, genau die richtigen Stoffe für einen herauszusuchen und haben ein wunderbares Gespür für Farben und Muster.
Doch neben der Schönheit reihen sich unzählige Strassen an Müll, Schutt und Dreck.
Wilde Tiere ernähren sich von Plastik, das in der heissen Sonne vor sich her verrottet.
Doch das ist nicht das einzige Problem, mit dem Djibouti zu kämpfen hat.
Die legalisierte Droge Kat, ein Kraut, das in der Backe zerkaut, aufputschend wirkt, gehört für die Menschen zum Alltagsverbrauch.
Djibouti hat für den Müll schon eine Lösung gefunden. Nein, kein Eiswagen. Das ist die Melodie des Müllwagens, der morgens um fünf durch die Strassen flitzt. So, und jetzt? Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und fange an mit Hey, wow, vielen Dank an Conny für diesen kleinen Eindruck aus Djibouti. 45 Minuten braucht man, um das komplette Land zu umrunden. Meinte sie nicht die Hauptstadt? Die Hauptstadt in 45 Minuten? Müssen wir nochmal reinhören. Ich dachte, das komplette Land. Djiboutis Hauptstadt, die ich kennenlernen durfte, ist, leicht zu merken, Djibouti. Und kann innerhalb von 45 Minuten komplett umrundet werden. Ja, du hast recht, es ist die Hauptstadt Djibouti, die um... Okay, ich dachte schon, das ganze Land könnte man mit 45 Minuten umkreisen. Jetzt fehlt mir aber allerdings der Maßstab, weil wie schnell kann man Köln umrunden? Keine Ahnung, das ist ein Kennwert, der relativ selten angegeben wird. Ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Vor allem, wie braucht man schon mehrere Stunden, wie gesagt fünf Stunden. Wow. Vielen, vielen Dank an Conny für diesen Eindruck aus Djibouti, großartig, danke schön. Ja, vielen Dank, spannend. Drittkleinst Land Afrikas. Es wird immer kleiner. Es wird immer kleiner, aber kann auch wieder grösser werden. Wir haben noch viel zu entdecken. Viele, viele Länder in Afrika haben wir noch nicht am Schirm gehabt. Aber eine ganze Menge schon, wie zum Beispiel. Ja, forget it, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht mehr. Wenn du die Rubrik nur alle 18 Folgen aus... Botswana, Burkina Faso. Uganda. Ja, Ruanda. Ich meine, wir hätten auch Ägypten.
Nigeria?
Ruanda hast du schon gesagt?
Das war Antenne Afrika!
Hey! Hey, wow, sehr schön, viel gelernt, viel gelernt, richtig viel. Ich wollte doch ganz kurz sagen zum Thema Wunder und den Miracle Busters, da haben uns viele Leute darauf hingewiesen, dass es tatsächlich schon einen Anime gibt, der sich mit genau dem Thema beschäftigt. Ja gut, dann lassen wir es. Es ist egal, was man macht, es gibt immer schon Anime, und zwar heißt es tatsächlich Miracle Ex, Vatican Miracle Examiner. Ja, und es gibt eines, vielleicht mehr, Vatican Miracle Examiner, auf Amazon man sich's anschauen. Falls ihr Bock habt auf ein
Vatikan-Anime,
let's go! Niemand hält
euch davon ab. Ich hab da so viel Bock drauf.
Ich auch. Ja. Aber wahrscheinlich
die finden dann da Dämonen und so
und kämpfen dagegen. Ja, das war überhaupt wahr.
Ja, mein Klavier spielt nachts automatisch.
Wirklich? Dann legen wir uns
jetzt hier mit Schlafsäcken in ihr Wohnzimmer und warten die Nacht, bis es anfängt zu spielen. Sehr realistischer, sehr langweiliger. Guten Morgen. Ja, Frau Schneider, wir waren jetzt die Nacht hier im Wohnzimmer und es hat nicht gespielt nachts. Das ist ja auch nur einmal im Jahr oder so. Das ist einmal im Jahr. Müssen wir jetzt das ganze Jahr hier bei Ihnen im Wohnzimmer wohnen? Nee, Sie können mir so einfach glauben, Sie wollen den Mythbusten. Nein, aber Glauben muss stopp. Glauben ist natürlich wichtig, aber Kontrolle ist wichtig, aber Kontrolle ist besser. Okay, kontrollieren Sie doch mal, ob es den Gott gibt. So, jetzt werden Sie frech. Ronny, schnapp sie dir. Der andere ist so The Muscle. Ja genau, weil es muss einen Muscle geben und es muss auch irgendwann so Anime-Fights geben und man freut sich ja, wo kommt es denn dabei zum Fight? Du hast so den einen kleinen mit dem Klemmbrett und daneben The Muscle, einfach so Ronny. Der dann Frau Schneider runterringt. Goliath. Goliath einfach. Goliath, schnapp sie dir. Ja. Schaut es euch an, ist, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Idee, richtig tolle Sachen. Und wenn wir jetzt schon dabei sind, uns wurde auch eine Schlagzeile immer und immer wieder geschickt, damit wir die jetzt einfach mal abgearbeitet haben, damit wir die einfach fertig machen können. Und zwar Ablage. Das Podcast-Ufo Ablage gab es die fantastische Schlagzeile Duck mimics human sound during mating. Ja, es gibt eine Ente, die gelernt hat, a musk duck, imitating human speech.
Wir hören rein.
Es gibt also eine Ente da draußen, die hat von Menschen das Mating Display gelernt, also das Balzverhalten,
und hat jetzt menschliche Sprache so oft gehört anscheinend, dass sie gelernt hat, es zu reproduzieren mit ihrem Musk-Duck-Schnabel und jetzt in der Balz tatsächlich menschliche Sprache benutzt. Hey, Süße! Und zwar sagt oder wurde gehört, dass diese Ente während ihres Balzverhaltens gesagt haben soll, You bloody fool! You bloody fool ist das, was diese Musk-Duck-Ente sich von Menschen abgeschaut hat. Wenn das kein Wunder ist, weiß ich es auch nicht. You bloody fool! You bloody fool! You bloody fool! You bloody fool! Vor allem, ist es das, was man von Menschen lernen kann? Nicht Hallo, wie geht's, kann ich dir helfen, sondern you bloody fool? Das ist unser Erbe. In welchem Park diese Ente da abhängt. Klingt nach England, klingt nach London, Hyde Park.
Ich weiß nicht, wo man da gerade ist,
aber es klingt so, als ob in diesem
Park geflucht wird.
Das heißt, vergesst jetzt
Quark, Quark, Quark
und ersetzt es in einem Kopf mit
You bloody fool. Ehrlich gesagt, es war auch noch nie
Quark, Quark, Quark. Es ist auch
nicht Wauwau.
Es ist auch nicht Kikiriki. Alles ist ein bisschen off und falsch. Ja, das stimmt. Und Quark, Quark ist eher Mäb, Mäb, Möb, Möb. Ja, Möb, Möb. Aber vor allem im Englischen gibt es ja Hooters mit Eulen, also Hut, Hut, Hut sollen Eulen anscheinend sagen. Hut. Ja, Hut T ja auch. Und im Deutschen gibt es aber kein wirkliches Euler. Wie macht die Eule? Uhu. Uhu. Uhu. Ja. Da ist halt kein T. Der Uhu ist sehr unomato-poetisch. Haben wir auf jeden Fall wieder das gelernt. Also falls ihr, also wir kriegen ja immer wieder Nachrichten zum Thema Dating, wie macht ihr das, wie seid ihr so erfolgreich, wie habt ihr so ein erfülltes Liebesleben. Wir wollen auch gerne so sein. Genau, und da ist natürlich die Frage, falls euer Flirtverhalten unter dem Niveau einer Ente liegt, könnt ihr das jetzt aufpeppen, indem ihr in euer Balzverhalten, Flirtverhalten, You Bloody Fool integriert. Es klappt anscheinend für einige Musk-Ducks. Und wenn die sich jetzt evolutionär fortsetzen, sagen irgendwann alle Enten, you bloody fool. Und wenn wir nichts auf dieser Erde hinterlassen, als ein paar verlassene Atomkraftwerke, wenn wir alle untergegangen sind, dann ist unser einziges Erbe als Menschheit, dass einige Enten in London sagen. Einige Maskdags rumlaufen mit You bloody fool, you bloody fool. Und die nächste Zivilisation, wenn dann aus Delfinen dann Menschen werden oder Delfine werden intelligent, die erforschen dann, warum sagen die You bloody fool, was ist da los? Und erst dadurch werden die Menschen überhaupt erst wieder entdeckt, dass es mal eine Menschheitszivilisation gab.
You bloody fool.
Fantastisch, oder?
Das ist fantastisch, ja.
Also ich glaube, das funktioniert auch als Balzverhalten. Also das ist ja klar, man kennt das ja als klassische. Wie erfolgreich ist denn diese Ente damit, mit you bloody fool? Naja, es gibt ja schon lange in Pickup-Artist-Kreisen die Strategie des Nagging, also jemanden so leicht anzu, leicht zu beleidigen, was ja mit You Bloody Fool jetzt mittlerweile biologisch bestätigt wurde, dass das anscheinend ein sinnvolles Verhalten ist. Ganz kurz, wir sind so kurz vor Pokémon, ne, also wenn es Tiere, wenn wir jetzt allen Tieren zumindest ihre Namen beibringen, also wenn es jetzt Muskdug Muskdug sagt. Das stimmt, das wäre gut. Kanzelle, Kanzelle! Genau, dann sind wir beim Pokémon. Ich wollte es nur sagen. Aber manche sind nicht auch manche... Kuh ist schon beim Pokémon. Genau, manche Tiernamen sind onomatopoetisch, wie Kuh doch auch. Man kann doch sich vorstellen, dass eine Kuh Kuh sagt, statt Muh, oder? Das kann man sich vorstellen, aber die tun es ja nicht. Das K habe ich noch nicht gehört bei einer Kuh.
Ja, Moment, aber müssen jetzt die Tiere,
wer muss jetzt nachziehen, die Tiere oder die Biologie?
Muss die Kuh jetzt lernen,
Kuh zu sagen, oder benennen wir
die Tiere so rum? In einer Zeit, wo Enten
mit You Bloody Fool rumlaufen
und mich beleidigen im offenen
Park, will ich dafür,
dass Tiere nachziehen müssen, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, also wir bringen Tieren jetzt
bei... Wir können nicht jetzt alles ändern.
Wir können jetzt nicht alle Schilder ändern, wo draufsteht
Kuhweide links.
Damals, man hat versucht, Flederer
einzuführen für Fledermaus,
hat nicht geklappt, wurde
abgeschmettert und das war das letzte
Mal, dass man gesagt hat, wir wollen ein Tier ändern.
Wenn ihr was ändert, ändert den fucking Ameisenbär,
ist ein irreführender Name, beleidigend.
Dinge sollten nicht nach dem benannt werden,
was sie essen, meine Meinung.
Aber ich bin auch zufrieden,
wenn jetzt nichts geändert wird.
Verhastet sich da immer,
verhatterst sich immer in so einem Politik-Sprech.
Ja, mein Gott,
würde man noch sagen dürfen,
das ist einfach unter aller Sau,
das geht doch nicht, das kann es doch wohl nicht sein.
Mir ist so gerade Sauen beleidigt, Schweine. Nee, Untersau. unter aller Sau. Das geht doch nicht. Das kann es doch wohl nicht sein. Mir ist gerade Sauen beleidigt. Schweine.
Nee, Untersau.
Unter aller Sau. Ja, gut. Du misst gerade mit zweierlei Maß.
Ich distanziere mich von meinem Ich von vor zwei Sekunden.
Okay.
Ich war irregeleitet.
Sie nehmen die Sau zurück.
Ich nehme Sau zurück.
Saustall.
Tatsächlich, saumässig ist ja gut. Im Französischen ist das äquivalent die Kuh. Also da sagt man Vachement, da sagt man Kuhmässig, statt Saumässig. Also interessant, ähnliches Wort, aber man hat sich dazu entschieden, dass es nicht Sau-cool ist, sondern Kuh-cool ist. Wohingegen es genau wie im Deutschen, im Englischen auch den Saustall gibt. Deine Wohnung sieht aus, meine Wohnung ist ein Saustall. Ja, stimmt. Gibt es genau, kannst eins zu eins übersetzen. Das ist cool. Wahnsinn. Wahnsinn. Sprache ist cool. Sprache ist cool. Wir bleiben dran an der Sprache. Wir wünschen euch viel Erfolg beim Sprechen diese Woche. Haut mal was raus. Lernt mal diese Woche. Ein Elfchen, macht mal ein Elfchen. Macht mal ein Elfchen und versucht mal, ein neues Wort zu lernen und das im Gespräch unterzubringen. Wirklich zu sagen, neues Fremdwort, ich will eloquenter klingen, versucht das unterzubringen, wünscht euch dabei viel Erfolg, haut rein, macht's gut, jetzt seid ihr auf euch alleine gestellt. Wir sind nämlich raus. Jetzt habt ihr eure Probleme wieder, die ihr gerade entfliehen wollt. Ciao!
It's the worst owl production.
Nee, warte mal.
Ja, das.